let me start proceedings off though by
asking your question Shawn obviously we
have just a sample of the brilliant cast
in this movie here today some new faces
and some returning faces to the series M
how is it for you as a filmmaker working
with such a talented ensemble well it's
actually you know although the the
visual effects and the spectacle and
action get a lot of attention my
favorite part of this franchise is this
cast they are not only extremely
talented but everyone kind of comes to
work with a sense of of play which is
required in a franchise like this and
that includes the group to my left and
many of the actors who aren't here day
and it also includes Robin of course who
was a core member of our troupe and we
were all extremely lucky to get to watch
him do his thing up close thank you very
much Sean okay and we have a question on
the end hit Merry Christmas by the way
I'm doing
I've got a question for for everyone
from my seven-year-old son calm you
might say what one thing in your house
would you like to come to life at night
okay so we started this yelling clean is
a concern so ever shall we start with
you Dan and worked out although know
what Shaw's but much more interesting
things in his house I feel like Stiller
has something you know okay he does
leave it well in my house we have a
thing called died November where every
night in November the dinosaurs come to
life and wreak havoc and every morning
my kids come downstairs and they've
either been through the fridge and it
torn stuff apartment ripped open a
magazine or something and it's fine for
the first couple of weeks but after
about 20 days of November my wife and I
kind of struggling creatively as to what
they're going to come up with next
so things do kind of come to life in my
house
but only in November hahaha music it is
you my turn it is so then I've gone
completely blind I think we're in the
same well yeah yeah so Matt oh yes what
was the question again slightly
intimidated
your house would you want to come to
work that well only for a limited amount
of time just real at night and maybe for
20 minutes I do have a portrait of
Napoleon and I would rather like to have
a chat with him at all kisses but Sir
Thomas quoi the hand you know oh yes
very very French very Napoleonic yes hey
what was the question again
um well I don't know I mean I can't say
my wife right on that note we can't top
that maybe looks going to this all right
do we have yes
goes down here custom for those divas
you play fantastic fellas lost wonderful
train is character what was the biggest
challenge for you oh my goodness um
probably the armor getting over the
weight of it I haven't quite appreciated
that when taking the role on if it has
to be great really fun I'm rehearsing
all the sword fights obviously without
the armor on most the time and um so
we've got the hang of that and then
trying everything with the armor on
after a few months got very very it wore
me down
let's put in that way yeah I had a very
bad back by the end of this Hungary
wishes via the center of potato hunts
former Empire
question on Owen and Dan because it's a
bit awkward for us young areas to laugh
at him because we know about his cruelty
in school all the stuff we learn and now
you took him also to London for a fun
trip it seems he's a jolly good fellow
and doesn't like I'm collectimus to you
two Americans are you go there of his
legendary cruelty and what will you tell
him how do you explain all this in the
afterlife my wife oh no I mean I I know
that he has a bad reputation
and I don't doubt obviously the truth of
it but you know these movies are fantasy
and and Patrick gives gives the
character some humanity and you know I
think there has to be that willing
suspension of disbelief and yeah we're
rewriting history okay but these you
know I don't think you can get to Shawn
yeah my wife - oh good keeps them these
franchise a whole kind of feedback you
do your kids give you one well it they
enjoy the movies and you know I don't
have for me my kids don't really watch
movies that I'm in too much but they
like these movies and it's been nice
because it's been over nine years now so
my kids really have grown up with them
and it was fun in this one because they
got to do a little bit in the movie too
and you know it's always the thing is
with kids you know when you're making
movies that you're a parent first and
that's how they see you and we have to
go in location for these movies which is
not always fun where you're not you know
with your kids the whole time and so but
at least it helps a little bit them
knowing that making one of these movies
you know that we can talk about it and
they actually can you know relate to
what I'm doing so that that part is good
and they really love the movies so it's
that's was fun
of the premier with them New York and
for them to see it and they gave it the
seal of approval
yeah sorry
all the questions will go you come late
into this franchise couple of questions
actually what is it what's it like
working with you dad oh yeah a lot of
people a lot of people don't know that
we're related but clearly we're both
belong and and my dad has taught me a
lot about comedy meeting time
unfortunately he like cast me out into
the Australian wilderness when I was
only a baby fun but I have the game
right
the other question was although he can't
say I'm going to be part of all I think
the franchise balance decision probably
we do keep getting that question I think
right now in our minds this third movie
brings closure to the franchise into the
characters I suppose that we can't
predict the future and definitely I we
have come to love Tilly the nightguard
the newer nightguard and we shall see
thank you I'm glad we'll see what
happens next I did keep my hat from the
maybe just in case like they needed me
again um and yeah I paid $650 to keep it
it's a question for better and this is
been quite an emotional movie to make
anymore because excuse me serpent oh no
sorry
so an artists around they'll have a lot
of it just it was a emotional to make
anywhere because it was perhaps the end
of Larry's journey yes and then after
the film catered obviously there was a
sad passing of Robin Williams and Mickey
Rooney and how has this affected your
experiences of the film and how you look
at the film now uh well I don't know in
terms of how I look at the film I mean I
just for me the experience I was never I
never took it for granted being able to
work with Robin because I was always a
huge fan of his and growing up for me he
was one of my comedic idols so and this
was the only chance to ever had to work
with him
so every time we got to work together in
these movies I was always excited and he
was very generous and kind and would
make everybody feel as if they were an
equal and it was fun to sort of you know
to be around him and have him treat you
that way but real in reality for me
under the surface I was always really
just a fan so I feel really lucky to
have that opportunity to to spend the
time with him and to and to be in the
movies with him and you know it's great
that the movies exist but for me it's
the experience I'll take away yes my
questions for both the new and the ten
cast view own and been also a living to
pilotage on backing vocals film huh how
do I complete the 2000 define charts and
for that old sermon and then what's been
the biggest advantage coming to this one
first response tears I think coming to
it fresh you you are invited to join a
very confident team not smug just really
confident and joyful and what they're
doing a very life enhancing it's like
going into someone's house where they're
comfortable in their home the way they
open the front door is really gracious
because they're very comfortable in
their own skin in their own work so the
Welcome is extraordinary you hit the
ground running it's a joy you never feel
you're being tested
particularly by shown shown is a
the director will give you the role and
you never ever feel again that you're
auditioning with some directors you feel
you're auditioning every day it's a very
uncomfortable feeling but not with this
whoops sorry not with this group they're
very very welcoming and lovely and it
was really absolutely was very exciting
for us to welcome Sir Ben yeah into them
into the cast and very really you know
it just changed the energy and all the
new cast members really changed the
energy when you know because we do have
that continuity but to have rebel and
Dan and and this you know just people
coming in from their own points of view
that keeps it alive it keeps it fresh
and that's that's very important hi my
question to rebel rebel um you had a
special areas kind of town I was
wondering how she developed this
character was it easy to master Jackson
most importantly actually is the
American character um I got it a museum
for 18 months prior to filming I spoke a
lot to Daniel day-lewis and he said if I
wanted to win an Oscar that so I I'd
have to put in the hard yards no I I
live with a great British comedian Matt
Lucas and so I tried to channel him a
little bit cheeky um but uh I just kind
of I loved being a little bit straight
as well just because uh that's just how
I like to roll like a gangster so I try
to bring a bit of that to - even though
that probably wasn't envisaged to be the
character courtly um that's quite a posh
name but out and what was the second
part of the tradition
I tasted a lot of ben stiller ah and
when he has that prosthetic son it
actually tastes a lot like rubbing
alcohol I did have I had prosthetic lips
on yeah he was very precious about them
so when am i kissing got quite romantic
and passionate was it concern yeah we
were trying to push the bounds for a
family movie there was social work some
raciest stuff between me and la that
unfortunately had to be cut unless if an
r-rated version is released then that
will get but what I like about Ben's
carte de la is Night at the Museum shame
but I love I love blossom mussels we
didn't get to see when band plays Larry
because they covered up by a jacket like
all the time but when he plays lots just
like arms out like he's just there I
notice he's wearing a jacket that was
you know that was when I was in
character and it's training six hours a
day and all that yeah yes then use this
second time this month we've be
traumatized because we saw you with
their rules I don't try the Ovilus
calmly yes I if you know that that was
what they have in store what you've done
it and the customs arrival do you think
that you will to like to try to Iron Man
charge perfectly this gorgeous weather
yes well first of all I mean you know
you did thank you I am I news I mean you
know when you're going out with bear
there's going to be challenges and you
know there's going to be weird food to
eat and I didn't quite know how intense
it would be or how dangerous would be
because you know they make you sign this
waiver and there's a reason why they do
that because you could die
listen you definitely could die and so
right from the beginning I realize so
this is a whole
different thing that I thought but he is
he's a super positive guy and if there's
somebody that you want to spend a night
in a cave with and cuddle up with and
snuggle with you know it's bear and yeah
I so yeah I mean in terms of their most
second part was well it was sky was nice
it was very beautiful until we started
filming we were there for like about a
half a day before and it was sunny and
beautiful and they serve roll the
cameras in the rain came in yes right
exactly absolutely um I don't know
whether the limpet diet is quite Fischer
try I've been doing quite a few
adventurous things lately I never
thought I'd be doing my own aerial
stunts which I did in this movie and a
lot in pitch perfect 2 which was he
coming out but I mean it would be really
fun to almost die not that much much you
could pass the microphone over there
thinking I was harassing them and once
you are scaring in bed and does what
have a friend when he's aboard he's very
excited at
Thank You Larry how old is he tell him
it's all fake so please a difference
also gotta get hash this whiskey Josie
happy tree pose for me younger fans you
actually get recognized for your images
well I find that yeah you do get
recognized I get recognized for Jedediah
but I find that I feel more questions
about the monkey than I do about about
me or Steve Coogan and I know that when
my son visited the set that seemed to be
what he was most excited about was to
see Dexter and who can blame uh yeah I
find that I get a lot of parents who
will recognize me and then they'll tell
them they'll shake their kid and go look
look look at him you know who that is
and I'll just look at me that's Larry
from the museum and a look at me mmm
believed that their kid wants a picture
with you but then the kids who's doing
exactly doesn't know that they wanted a
picture with you guys hey mommy get to
exercise some of your skills yeah in in
at the end slightly darker bleak away
yeah it was really nice to do some
comedy hadn't done any since I was at
college and I was partly footlights when
I was a student and did a bit stand-up
back then never wanted to be a stand-up
but I'd always wanted to try it and yeah
I've followed quite a straight-laced
path since then doing a lot of sort of
costume drama and that kind of thing so
um yeah it was delightful to get to work
alongside these guys who are you know
world-class improvisers and to learn
that art as we went along as it was
amazing very much as anywhere else have
a question
say yes and I went to the gentleman over
there this way thank you wishes anyone
that does that in particular possible
have you had any feedback or gob notes
that the film will help encourage a new
generation in some actual reasons to
learn real things uh I think she wants
to hear it from me and I could give your
answer forgive me yep by ancestry matter
you know I think since the since the
first movie you know museums
particularly the American Museum of
Natural History New York have started
having sleepovers in museums and that's
become it's become a thing to have spend
a night in the museum and yeah I think
it has sort of encouraged museum
attendance worldwide and it just it
really feeds into how you're supposed to
go around the museum which is with a
with an active imagination really and
look at all these things you know
inanimate objects in glass cases and
imbue them with a with a kind of crazy
narrative and certainly my kids going
around in that with History Museum now
imagined stories behind every dinosaur
in every artifact and yeah I think I
think they very much encourage that in a
sort of active and fun and silly
engagement with history I certainly
learned a lot from you know watching
Bill and Ted growing up and you know
it's not exactly a historical
documentary but I certainly want to win
and looked up so-crates
[Music]
lovely thank you oh yes sir oh this is
so cast as potentially the last sermon
series if any of you taking you
keepsakes mementos reset
I want my sword did you get a sword
we didn't send you the sword oh yeah
okay I'll make that happen it's real to
the real one please
I got a tablet I got one of the tablets
yeah
it was given to me by Sean physically I
haven't you know I haven't gotten up in
at night to honeymoon him but enjoy
later I have not been in the moon that's
right okay any any of the questions
right now I one thing we haven't touched
on its fact that this is a we're
actually in the city that this movie set
in a short if I could ask you a at
London what did London add as a backdrop
to the series well so much I mean not
only I guess the City of London played a
pretty big role because we realized
after the second museum film that we've
never really kind of gone beyond the
museum walls so this central idea of the
magic spilling out from the museum and
these characters colliding with the real
world that was very fun to do in Chicago
Square and the West End and in various
places and then the British Museum has
been amazing and we actually filmed more
inside the British Museum than we've
ever filmed in any museum in the whole
series so they were very forthcoming and
gives the movie a certain reality that
kind of would never be quite the same if
it were all done digitally so I was
great access yes this gentleman just hit
also when we were filming her rained
every city away which was kind of insane
made perfect yeah I would miss ball
beating off if you could pick watch
seeing what
my actual parents appealing what would
be I love the journey he'll come here
that was in the second movie I thought
like that was him roofing weird
still I was just like such cool comedy
and so that's why I I tried to bring in
this one
I dropped the aerial dogfight in the in
the second movie I'd like to see
Lancelot in an aeroplane their own
airplane wonderful
Pokemon and I think we've got time for
one more question yes if you'd like to
take that microphone and you've got
quite a lot of action and seeds in this
particular part and sneaking me passage
out summer actually taking to your other
kick more comedic roles is to me like to
go over to a bit more and I love is it
you daring anyways what do you like to
do and buting you know honestly I I mean
I I like doing it in the right context
like this kind of a movie with you know
where feels like it's organic or in a
comedy where you know like you know
something like Tropic founders and like
that where it just feels you know the
tone of it is that but I mean I think
real action movies are so they've gone
to such a crazy level of you know what
they do and those things and the people
who do them are very good at those
things specifically so I I don't have a
burning desire to do that but it's
always fun to do that kind of stuff and
in this movie was interesting in that in
particular because Dan had to do all
that sword fighting in that sequence I
was doing stuff with my flashlight of
course but there's nothing there you
know there's nothing there at all so
literally that that's all computer
animators were just minding so really
like what you should do to prepare is
take mine classes for these things
because right I mean it wasn't your
there's nothing to connect with there's
no I was just shown yelling it's coming
from the left yeah and sometimes would
be a guy with a tennis ball and into the
polls right um right it feels really
silly when you're doing feels really
silly but if you don't commit to it a
hundred percent then it's you know then
it's never going to work
you